hey guys how's it going so I bought this
at the craft store
the other day when I was looking for
something to some crap because I love to
craft you know wait
that's the de Kooning hell yes bro I'm
not so sure I call this or classify it
as a baking video because it's called
yummy nummies mini kitchen magic I've
never seen this before when I got up to
the checkout counter the girl was like
it to you for this edible I'm like I
have absolutely no idea is for joining
our initially flavor is clearly very
very healthy for you dinner delights and
six plots is there anything in here this
is like air it's magic make it big enjoy
because it's good nothing in that box
high walls and extend mini pizzas I've
had this for like four weeks and oh I
just wanted to open at night I just sit
and I were to wait I'm going to see
there's real no more authentic pizza
authentic reaction of box and air max
sit up go with a bunch other ones but
I'm just going to be like sort of up hey
you want to come over maybe yummy nummy
well I don't the instructions are on the
inside
yes they are nice Oh super tiny
I gradually like the napping tiny
probably seeing remove it's my favorite
who knows I was at Pixar back in the day
would never work real mess films and use
need yeah my fault about that old look
at the claws what's the change is it
smoke a routine excuses ok look the
party's work remove the tray package new
pencils from packaging use a scissors it
says use a scissors scissors all going
to use their interest to cut the kitchen
magic a a world in the inherited one
like right here nothing done sit yes
music ends
does it seem don't should do that now
wait there's a an asterisk
was it say any staff requiring use of
scissors in microwave Chevy performance
by an adult should we go find an adult
we're too late
I'm here you're here and train one make
I have seven scoops of crap powder with
three scoops of water
why second scoop but with scoop looking
to you want to get some water ready
looking a couple million Riel and there
we go make several skip suppressed
no oh three water it when I begin
without you well buddy was at how three
I wasn't counting shoot four five six
seven cool
one two three
this is routed by the mixture evenly
into trays two or three four and five I
think I might be sure this is like this
is our Lucia oh my god these are so cute
that's not very not divide it evenly
okay purposes into these tiny train two
three four five the cake comes in hot
iron I put it in the little spoon Hall
okay give me that she's your finger no
one touch it a smooth rose honestly is
fine the lootable people to lose okay
after the future microwave depressed for
10 seconds and allow to cool for 30
seconds Wow the press into the trailer
your finger looks like is that before
you're frying your brain yeah maybe
it'll help
Wow Wow
they [ __ ] up Wow oh it's hot Oh God
this is it you know flatten it with your
fingers Oh God so wait 30 seconds very
exciting two men Platinum my favorite
six-foot do I can go I think they're
doing legal things I don't have any
fingerprints out collagenous I love
being your weight off open the sauce
zero to two Beckett got cocky off of the
air to tail okay what we do with that
whereas in six I think that was a
feeling what I want to do one and a half
and one scoop of water mix well and
ready I'm ready to mix so you can need a
little bit more water
she's a little how does that turn it off
open the box over the floor piece of
crap place to treat this right back in
the back door supply seconds wait one
minutes ago Oh Nick whoa
lean back in because we'll be jelly
cheese 0 to 3 while still doing that
divide one scoop of the cheese how many
subway how many thought ten seconds oh
by second school alive today
well I real fresh look at that just like
fresh feather probably just as fresh I
like that I need you
but now but this is wait this is another
expression trash mother's Wednesday
well I think they might be a little bit
more fresh gonna continue on a moon both
exceptional because finally it's not
mean how do you get out of there how the
heck maybe felt fully cooked
that's it right serve your pizza on the
pink appeal and joy repeat steps 2 to 6
look at all these things there's a
sundae maker donut delight Oh guys if
you liked this video please let me know
because if you do I'm going to be making
every single one of these things play me
LF L
chariots can't even beat
occasionally pizza check out like a
sweet pizza like I can't even say it's
McIlroy oh I'm sorry I realize also
supported with the help of a small party
bite
I want simple I'm on my statically diet
it tastes like a seasoned gummy so how
we explain with it tasted so well it
doesn't even dough is a little bit
grainy the sauce feels like a little bit
of sweet elegant jelly
yeah still it's like a jelly if you put
some spice in it I'll fake Pizza like
never used to have a bunch of all use
like don't throw a lunch of those under
the bus like that this is not taste like
a Lego it's upgraded lunchable so this
is like a generated lunchable it's
actually a really cool idea and I think
this is actually kind of a cool little
gift probably to like get young children
that are up six plus this is not so
authored by the way I brought a bunch of
you can see we have good makeup cake
already
I don't have them you just allow them
how can we get them and then we'll talk
Matt comes movement you be sure to add
his left reactions all right we'll see
you guys later thanks for watching bye
unlike many pieces to specify where's
this many Pizza poin then I know poison
to the grass or I mean we're dying
that's our time is up oco-2 coffee
pick me now
this is how I like that I'm not going I
got a little uh movie today john way too
big okay bye
[Music]
just try it
you know me I saw everything Pizza
smelled it and you said it was weird and
I don't like it I know no I'm not our
I'm stubborn
yeah no cooled up just try it
oh happy this will help you I'm not you
movie snack now you try it you're
ruining the video I old like yeah
weren't you a mad thing so see faziz
microwave is first it's a cheese I'll
show you the box yeah I'll be the dancer
[Applause]
it's just a tiny mini tough what's your
business
yeah I mean it's not like good it's not
but it's not bad it's just a mean tiny
pizza it doesn't taste good yeah it's a
tiny mini pizza oh you're lying to me no
okay did he actually use yeah oh my god
yeah
no we all tried it and it was fine I
mean it's not a good taste but it's not
like bad it's just whatever it looks
pretty good my nails match it so that's
nice
it's actually in pretty good condition
the question that I have is we were
startup and how will I sleep this in
even if I have a converter